in an exclusive cbs news interview
president biden says he expects next
year's super bowl to be played
in a full stadium but it will be very
difficult he says to reach herd immunity
against the coronavirus by the fall
the president is pushing ahead with the
democrats covet relief bill but
former president trump's second
impeachment trial threatens to
overshadow it
nancy cordes is in wilmington delaware
for us where the president
spent the weekend nancy good morning to
you good to see you
good morning good to see you too
president biden watched the super bowl
with family here in a windy wilmington
after sitting down for that wide-ranging
interview
with cbs evening news anchor and
managing editor norah o'donnell they
talked about the toll that this pandemic
has taken on school children
and he said that guidance is finally
coming
this week for how schools can safely
reopen
you have to have fewer people in the
classroom you have to have
ventilation systems that have been
reworked president biden told nora
o'donnell that
federal guidance for a return to school
is coming this week
our cdc commissioner we just named is
going to be coming out
with science-based judgment within i
think as early as next wednesday
as the layout what the minimum
requirements are the president also laid
out some of his
red lines in the next covid relief bill
you've said you're not compromising on
the 1400 dollar checks
no he said he is willing to deal on some
things
like lowering the income cut off for
stimulus checks
and holding off on a fifteen dollar
minimum wage
but on other provisions like four
hundred dollar a week unemployment
benefits for the next six months
mr biden is holding firm to the
frustration of a group of senate
republicans
who had hoped he would meet them halfway
the administration is showing very
clearly they don't care if they have to
work with us
the covid bill could be overshadowed
this week by the second
senate impeachment trial of former
president trump
accused of inciting an insurrection last
month
we're going to walk down to the capitol
over the weekend wyoming republican liz
chaney was censured by her state party
but the congresswoman said
she did not regret voting to impeach
what we already know
is enough for his impeachment this is
not something that we can simply look
past or pretend didn't happen or try to
move on
a conviction in the senate is unlikely
this impeachment in the eyes of most
republicans
is an unconstitutional exercise mr biden
told cbs news that his predecessor
should no longer get classified
intelligence briefings why not because
of his radic behavior
unrelated to the insurrection
after that interview white house press
secretary jensachi clarified that
president biden has
deep trust in his intelligence officials
to make the ultimate
determination about whether president
trump should continue to receive
those intelligence briefings also over
the weekend president biden
was among those paying tribute to george
schultz who was
president reagan's secretary of state
schultz president biden said was a man
of honor and ideas he died on saturday
at the age of 100 years old anthony
an extraordinary career in public
service nancy thank you